all right mr mccarthy this of course is
the minibar you're gonna want to keep it
locked a lot of these items are quite
pricey take one of these vodkas for
example the second you take it out
there's a sensor underneath it that's
how we know it's missing that's how we
know to charge you i'm not going to pay
you for that yep you're not goes right
to your room right to the credit card
you already gave us convenience i hear
that plastic breaking
that there's a point of no return we
know you opened it don't try to replace
it it's yours i'm not planning on using
this mini bar
okay then i will
i'm not gonna pay for that vodka come on
i'll get the next one it's like
rose before hoes